when there's certainly a shorthand we
have from you know having this been the
third film we've shot together now and
you don't spend a chunk of your shooting
time getting to know one another
you know we pick up where we left off
and have developed a great friendship
along the way and I don't like from the
beginning we were lucky we just had
chemistry in the same kind of enthusiasm
and you know I'd this the relationship I
look forward to you know it's really
delving into every time is being able to
ask the questions that for loci haven't
really had the acute focus to do so yet
and this instance was that you know that
was a great opportunity we had I Love
You Man it's absolutely true it's you
know from from the beginning of Kenneth
Branagh so all the way through Joss
Whedon's Avengers and into into Allen's
dark world it's it has been an amazing
adventure for both of us and and the two
characters define each other and need
each other and all acting is about what
happens in the space between people and
and and the more you trust each other
the deeper you can go and when I'm on
set with Chris whatever he serves I'll
return and he'll return them back and
and and that is the joy of it for me
another theme in this is that sibling
rivalry knows you've got two brothers
and I just wondered whether you drew a
relationship with them to inform your
interactions with Loki neither of them
have attempted to take over the universe
just yet but I think I don't have the
same reaction if I did what we're
competitive the siblings are and kind of
everything from sport and backyard
cricket football surfing to who's
controlling them I control watching TV
this industry not so much you know I
think we certainly all three of us
understand the sort of royalty and
inconsistency of you know had the work
and
you know we'd help each other with
auditions and always have and whatever
scripts are working on and you know
you're not direct competition anyway and
and and it's more of a kind of team
effort with this this than than anything
else
you